primero que nada estamos dolidas
indignadas porque no es justo que hayan
pasado diez y cinco años y volvemos a
cero como nuevamente con el índico de
alberto fujimori
esto pasó de diciembre y ahora
nuevamente de 2022 en nuestra lucha
continúa
donde establecemos muchas veces por
estas respuestas que son desfavorables
para nosotros las víctimas que están
falleciendo que con esta pandemia aún
han fallecido muchas y aunado a esto a
una justicia que está tardando
lo que estamos es buscando caminos para
que este indulto no proceda porque
justamente la corte interamericana
reprochado el indulto de alberto
fujimori en el 2017 y esto vamos a
nosotros apelar para en la corte
interamericana haga prevalecer porque
esto es tradición de forzadas fue un
delito de lesa humanidad él tiene que
pagar la culpa de este delito que se
cometió a caer en un genocidio contra
las mujeres y nuestro cuerpo y la vida
que estamos llevando
en la salud física y mental sobre todo
estamos pasando que no se dejó si se
llama más de 25 años
usted ha dicho que están buscando
caminos para revertir esta situación hay
organizaciones de víctimas trabajando en
algún tipo de apelación
si tenemos nueve casos justamente
también en labor de perdón de la onu en
la ciudad que es otro camino a pedir
justicia no los abogados internacionales
también están viendo esto de la
extradición que incluyan alberto
fujimori porque él está extraditado por
otros casos más no por esterilizaciones
y en este caso estilizaciones forzada es
un delito de lesa humanidad y merecemos
por respeto y dignidad a más de 300.000
mujeres y 22.000 varones que fueron
víctimas que se haga justicia ya han
pasado cinco gobiernos cinco
accionamientos y es indignante que la
corrupción y todo lo que está pasando
los gobiernos que que no cierran las
puertas que no hay compromiso que no
tengo nosotros merecemos respeto
por memoria y dignidad y brevemente
señora carabajal podría contarnos cómo
usted vivió esta situación cómo fue
victimizado
bueno a mí me se izaron el 18 de
septiembre de 1996 en san juan de
miraflores a mi me condicionaron
escondieron a mi hijo y después de
muchas horas tuvieron que exigir mi
familiares para que me lo entreguen
con un triste doloroso y no es solamente
se incitó los 25 años que hemos pasado
con nuestra familia nuestra salud física
y mental y ahora los gobiernos que son
indigentes y no nos ayudas